[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
or is that refer think with Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast about
death where my brother and I answer
questions give you dubious advice and
bring you all the week's news from both
Mars and AFC Wimbledon hey John how you
doing good
actually not not good a couple things
first off I've had a bad week just like
a difficult personal week health-wise as
you know Hank this is personal but I
have a I have a brain illness called
obsessive-compulsive disorder and I've
been in the process of switching
medications which has not been fun
also in possibly even worse news the
Taylor Swift summer that we were blessed
with here in Indianapolis has officially
ended there was 48 straight hours of
rain and now it is cold so the darkness
has descended the sky here in
Indianapolis is so close to the ground
that I feel like I could reach up and
touch it and Taylor Swift is well and
truly gone how are you I'm so so sorry
to hear that it is also quite gloomy
here if I looked out the window and
didn't know anything about what time it
actually was I would guess that it was
about 7 o'clock at night yeah it is in
fact noon it's just really dark and
overcast and in personal health news if
as long as we're going there I take a
medicine that makes my life much much
better but also makes everything taste
bad hmm
it's awful yeah I also am feeling very
frustrated with medication side effects
at the moment it it doesn't do it all
the time I'll have I'll go weeks and
I'll be like oh it went away yeah and
then I'll wake up one morning and I'll
be like wow my mouth tastes really bad
and I'll brush my teeth and I'd be like
wow my tooth toothpaste tastes really
bad then I'll go have breakfast and I'll
be like this is there's something wrong
with this banana and it turns out that
that's just my life for the next few
weeks mmm a comedy podcast about two
middle-aged men and their chronic health
problems well you got to know that life
isn't gonna always be milkshakes I was
just talking to my psychiatrist about
this very thing which is that when I was
in college and I
became aware that I was mentally ill I I
believed
somehow that this was something this was
like a problem of one's teens and early
20s but it turns out that used you are
stuck inside of the same brain for your
entire life so anyway I am doing okay I
am doing much better today than I was on
Monday when we were first supposed to
record this podcast and I just had to
cancel can I read you a short poem that
will hopefully cheer us both up let's do
it all right it's by EE Cummings it's
called I thank you God for most this
amazing I think you got for most this
amazing day for the leaping greenly
spirits of trees and a blue true dream
of sky and for everything which is
natural which is infinite which is yes I
who have died and alive again today and
this is the son's birthday this is the
birthday of life and of love and wings
and of the gay great happening in
limitedly
earth how should tasting touching
hearing seeing breathing any lifted from
the know of all thing human merely being
doubt unimaginable you now the ears of
my ears awake and now the eyes of my
eyes are opened ie comings a poem from I
think the 1940s but I'm not positive
that was nice thanks for that poem John
yeah it's a good one he Cummings you
know specializes in in the poetry of
surprisingly optimistic that would be my
description of a cummings poetry well
let's let's answer a question from from
Dell who is surprisingly optimistic and
says dear Hank and John when I'm seated
in any public restroom or private or
portable restroom and I see a toilet
paper roll that is set to dispense from
the under position I assume that that
the the toilet paper is coming from
toward the wall out from under
no matter the effort required I will
switch it to the over it is my obsession
with correcting people's obvious
oversights and rudeness am i a monster
well not a monster
possibly a person who's responding to an
obsessive interest with a compulsive
response but no not a monster in fact
Hank as you may know one of the longest
Wikipedia articles
is devoted to the question of whether
toilet paper should dispense you know
over the roll or under the roll from the
front of the roll or from the back of it
my response to this is this question
which is it's a big question for sure
but my response to it is you know did
you know that half a million people are
going to die of malaria this year John
but did you know that my dog if it is
wrist but if it is if it is set in the
over position my dog will grab on to
that and run out of the bathroom with
the toilet paper in her mouth and drag
it around the entire house but if it is
in the under position she isn't able to
do that so you know what that makes me
think that makes me think that the
previously the the the Wikipedia article
I previously believed to be exhaustive
isn't and that there is this fascinating
new data point that needs to be added to
that Wikipedia article in order in order
for it to be the the complete work that
it ought to be so yeah I I mean I think
that I in the over position I am all for
the over position because I don't have
Hanks dog but I also I also respect
people who believe in the under position
yes I well yes i I also AM over in
upstairs where the dog does not go so I
completely understand and I I am quite
confused by people who who are in favor
of the under position without the dog in
the equation it's fine of course you
know it's your toilet paper you can do
what you will if you're in someone
else's house I would ask that you not
switch their toilet paper I agree I
think that we have to respect the
sanctity of one another's homes when it
comes to our toilet papering decisions
Hank I'm wondering if we can move on to
a time sensitive question this one is
pressing
unfortunately this question arrived
three and a half weeks ago 12-year old
ginger writes Dear John and Hank have
you ever accidentally glued your fingers
together and if so what advice would you
offer to a kid who may or may not
currently have fingers glued together
hey
I can't believe that we've waited three
weeks and then like a full ten minutes
into the podcast before getting to this
vital question poor ginger at this point
her skin cells have likely merged her
fingers will be together for the rest of
her life it's exactly what has probably
happened and I apologize deeply and
ginger is just listening to the podcast
staring at her perpetually bound fingers
and thinking Hank and John you've let me
down
I'm sorry ginger the thing to do is put
in some some rubbing alcohol but it's
too late now your skin cells have merged
you've just got the one finger that's
huge
nail polish remover is also a good one
get different solvents you know
turpentine the kind of stuff that takes
paint off of walls
that's that stuff's good for that and
yes yes I have John have you ever glued
your fingers together I have yeah I used
to really like the feeling of the
stickiness when I would glue my thumb to
my my pointer finger you know with
superglue for a while there you can
still unstick Andry stick and unstick
Andry stick and I really like that
tactile sensation but then eventually
you do it one too many times and
suddenly you can't unstick it and I
think that maybe is the situation that
ginger found herself in you know
fortunately I I was able to ask someone
what I should do and they gave me a nail
polish but that's because I didn't ask
my favorite podcasters who clearly did
not did not answer it in an appropriate
time frame we have another question from
Amy I'm fascinated by this question who
asked dear Hank and John if I get in a
helicopter and hover for 24 hours would
I end up in the same place I started
because of the Earth's rotation let's
assume for the plausibility of the
question that I have enough fuel to
hover that long and that I've pointed
the helicopter in the right direction to
correspond with the earth's tilt
oh you want to take this one John yeah
this seems like a question for me Amy
thanks for thanks for the thoughtful
question so if you get in a helicopter
and you hover do you know by the way
that when Hank was a little boy he
called helicopters helicopters so he's
gonna act like he knows the answer to
this question but do you trust a man who
once called helicopters helicopters
anyway if you get in a helicopter and
you hover in the exact same spot for 24
hours you will rotate with the earth so
you will still be in the same spot
because you will be still in the Earth's
atmosphere and that is the answer to
your question yeah so basically am i
right yeah yeah yeah you will stay I
mean it depends like basically like the
winds will blow you around like if you
try and stay at a point in the
atmosphere the atmosphere does move
around but obviously the atmosphere does
not stay in the same place while the
Earth spins underneath it the atmosphere
moves along with the earth and spins
along with the earth everything on the
earth you know when we are on the earth
we are moving very fast relative to the
center of the earth but we are not
moving very fast relative to the surface
of the earth we are not moving at all
relative to the surface of the earth
because the surface of the earth spins
with us and so when that helicopter
takes off it is also it is it is staying
at the same speed relative to the
surface of the earth which means that it
the earth does not spin underneath it
and also the atmosphere does not spin or
the earth does not spin underneath the
atmosphere so you end up you know being
stuck at a point in the atmosphere that
might get blown around some as winds
happen but it's certainly not blowing as
fast as it would if suddenly the the
earth was moving in the atmosphere
wasn't which would be completely
catastrophic and would destroy
everything on earth yes so if we can
just back up I was correct yes I love
that feeling god that feels good I'm so
good at science yeah I I'm really proud
I'm proud of you as well John here is a
question from Megan she writes dear John
and Hank I am a senior in high school
who is currently looking for
scholarships I found a
scholarship that offers $10,000 but it
would require me to read Ayn Rand's
Atlas Shrugged and write an entire essay
about how much I loved the book and the
theories behind it it's an awful awful
thing to have to do but $10,000 is a lot
of money I could use to pay tuition what
should I do
well oh my god I think the the you know
like there's two options here one is
just to is to just consider the world an
unfair place and move on the other is to
read Ayn Rand's Atlas Shrugged write an
amazingly exceptionally good essay about
how wonderful it is get the scholarship
and then as soon as the check clears
write an amazing essay about how
destructive the worldview put forth in
Atlas Shrugged is and how you got a
scholarship that required you to write
that to write the opposite of that and
then post that on medium where it will
get a billion views and you will become
semi-famous yes yes right yes your your
medium story will be entitled how I
scammed a bunch of iron Rand fans out of
ten thousand bucks which is the ultimate
I would argue like the ultimate use of
the iron race absolutely is disgu a mine
ran founds out of ten thousand bucks
who are forcing you to read Atlas
Shrugged in exchange for a scholarship
which by the way like in a larger sense
like points to one of the big problems
of Objectivism the fact that we even
need ten thousand dollar scholarships
because obviously some people have
access some people are able to pay for
college and others aren't it I would
argue that like in the existence of the
scholarship and the fact of the
necessity of the scholarship lies much
of the problem of the the idea of some
of the ideas of Objectivism
so I wouldn't point that out in the
essay I would wait and then point it out
in your essay about the essay I'm very
excited for this Meaghan congratulations
in advance okay let's let's have a can
we have a serious talk for a moment now
that we feel like we've done a good job
for Megan my act my you know I would be
very careful about doing this because
there's you know there's a large chance
that she won't get the scholarship but
that's too bad
but so baby don't waste too much time on
it but it would be amazing
however I will say that I did get a I
did get an ask on my tumblr that said
something to the effect of you know you
guys pride yourself on being objective
on being open and and like imagining
others complexly and and yet the way
that you treat Randi and philosophy and
those who adhere to it makes me feel
very much like you don't imagine those
people complexly and that you were just
being mean and closed off from them yep
we have another question Hank it's from
Katrina yeah I guess I hear what they're
saying and I probably am not fair to you
know every strand of Randi and
philosophy but I do find the idea that I
should be tolerant of intolerance
problematic
I just deeply disagree with with that
world you know I might be wrong and I
might even be wrong to characterize it
as intolerance and I'm happy to
acknowledge that I might be wrong and
that I often am wrong but I'm still
going to like you know vociferous least
and for what I believe in you know yeah
all right I think that is I think that
is handled that and probably that person
stop listening to our podcast anyway
sorry to lose you person well it's in
the past now Hank let's move on to
Katrina's question who writes Dear John
and Hank knowing that Hank has a love of
corn dogs I thought of him the other day
when I came across a corn dog donut it
was a donut with a Dijon glazed tomato
jam and crushed pretzels topped with a
mini corn dog that sounds disgusting
this got me thinking about weird food
combinations that seem off-putting at
first but then surprise you with how
delicious they are what weird food
combinations do you enjoy dftba Katrina
well just to answer this first the
weirdest food combination that I enjoy
is herring with literally anything
herring with peanut butter herring with
mustard herring with mayonnaise herring
with other herrings like herring stuffed
inside of herring stuffed inside of
herring I
there is no variety of herring that I do
not enjoy what about a herring ducking
it's a herring stuffed with a duck stuck
stuffed with a chicken
the herring ducking
a hair ducking so like a bunch of
herring stuffed inside of a duck and
then the duck is stuffed inside of a
chicken no no no it's it it sounds
delicious is there any way I can start
is there any way I can start with the
herring and just eat all of them i baron
cooked in duck fat are you kidding that
sounds amazing
I've never had I don't feel like I've
ever had herring oh my god how do you
call yourself a person what is what is
herring is it come in like a can it does
sometimes come in a can it comes in all
kinds of ways it's a fish fish is a
small fish small fish you just eat it
eyes bones hmm yeah yeah that's often
pickled I agree that that is that is
just well that's just a weird food I
love peanut butter and I guess anything
you combine it with is gonna be a weird
food combination I want to say to
Katrina I love peanut butter jelly and
hair I like a peanut butter jelly
sandwich with the bread made out of
herring man that sounds really awful you
should make a video about this I want to
see you just eat a bunch of herring
combinations if that's something you
enjoy that you should just do that on
video and get views mmm sounds delicious
the herring challenge John Green John
Green's herring challenge I want I want
to like do the music for it but um Papa
Papa John green the herring challenge
he eats herrings with everything hey do
you like any weird food saying well
first I want to say that I love the idea
of this corn dog doughnut the only
problem with it being that the corn dog
is on top when clearly that the dog
should be in the middle that's how it's
a corn dog it's it's a it's a dog
surrounded by carbs right and to have
put it on top when you could when you
could have inserted the dog into the
belly of the beast I'm very upset at
that doughnut shops lack of ingenuity
but maybe they want to have it right on
top there so people don't accidentally
eat it thinking that it's gonna be
regular donut and then encounter meat in
the middle and this is loose with their
meat in their mouth which happened to me
the first time I gave a friend of mine a
corn dog once she was like I've never
had a corn dog and I was like oh you
have a bite of mine you can have the
first bite and then she took a bite and
she said they're mean this yeah
yes they could have explained the idea
to you but yes yes there is that it is
just basically just meat with a little
bit of not meat but you can't see any of
the meat and I understand how that that
could be confusing weird food
combinations that I I greatly enjoy I
like to put anything inside of a
tortilla like pasta like like like yeah
like spaghetti with meatballs inside of
a tortilla or mac and cheese inside of a
tortilla basically I don't know if
that's a weird food combination but that
is something that I did a lot as a child
and I will used to put baked beans in my
macaroni and cheese which is very good I
used to put I really like the idea Hank
of you opening up an unusual burrito
restaurant I mean that sells uh
spaghetti and meatballs burritos or
peanut butter and jelly burritos you
can't say that I have any shortage of
ideas I I'm just full of them full of
amazing ideas everybody's gonna go for
that
grilled mac and cheese burrito no but
that might be your first truly billion
dollar idea you know like I mean that I
could see that rivaling Chipotle the
unusual burrito shop
no I'm just kidding our first billion
dollar idea was Jurassic Mars
that's definitely yet I don't know why
we haven't been developing this idea
more I think someone explain to me why
how eight weeks after we invented
Jurassic Mars there still isn't two
Jurassic Mars movie
I don't know I'm very frustrated oh man
we should we ask answer another question
Hank
yeah let's answer Bridget's question
okay who asks dear Hank and John we're
talking about we were talking about
family the other day and I said
relatives to refer to my grandparents as
well as my husband my husband was thrown
off because using the term related to to
refer to him sounded like he was my
cousin or something he's not my cousin
so my question is this should I use the
word related when talking about a
married couple and if not what word
would I use is there a word for that
well I would argue that family is not
just blood I don't I don't agree with
the notion that family is merely blood I
kind of think that you decide your
family and that's one of the things that
you commit to when you commit to
marriage and one of the things to me
that's cool about marriage so I think
that I think that you are related to
your husband
but though it does sound weird when I
say it that way yes because because the
word related sounds as if you are as it
sounds the meaning of the word it seems
to mean that you are connected to them
by blood but if you look at the what the
word actually means as in you have a
relationship with them and thus are
related to them right by law then yes
you are related to your husband now hey
can we can we get to what I think is at
the core of this question which is are
there any famous people who were married
to their first cousins oh yeah lots oh
yeah lots Charles Darwin was married to
his first cousin Charles Darwin sure she
was great they had a great marriage they
did they had a great man you know who
else was married to his first cousin
Albert Einstein look at also Saddam
Hussein oh well maybe a little less
exciting also the the son of a a mil
Christopher Robin Milne who the original
Christopher Robin was based on a Milne
of course wrote Winnie the Pooh and it
was one of the reasons there was a lot
of tension between the author of Winnie
the Pooh and the person that it was just
it was ostensibly written about was
because AMM did not did not approve of
Christopher Robin Milne marriage to to
his first cousin also Edgar Allen Poe
was married to his first cousin who died
he got married to her when he was 26 and
she was 13 that that's a mmm that's a
decision and then she died it at 24 and
inspired many of his most famous poems
so yeah I'd you know do you know I'm not
here to judge you
that's all I'm saying I actually I am
gonna go ahead and judge Edgar Allan Poe
it's not okay to marry to marry your 13
year old cousin it's just not we
actually I'm gonna I'm going to strip
all all connection from this story so
that people can't track it down but but
there is a person who we know who fell
in love with their first cousin when
they were very young they they never
made anything of it they got married to
different people and then we're both
widowed or widowed word or whatever and
then when they were in their 80s got me
that is a thing that happened to a
person I know yeah and fascinatingly in
this in the place where they live that
is not illegal because the law
specifically states that you can't marry
your first cousin
unless not unless there's no chance of
childbearing and since they were in
their 80s there wasn't indeed indeed all
right well I'm glad that this podcast
has so far what did you say
today's podcast is brought to you by
post-menopausal cousin marriage
post-menopausal cousin marriage legal in
some places today's podcast is brought
to you by the sensation of having your
fingers sticking together but not quite
being stuck together what a pleasant
sensation and yet so dangerous today's
podcast is also brought to you by side
effects of medication side effects of
medication that unfortunate necessity
today's podcast is brought to you by the
an R and Atlas Shrugged Scholarship
Foundation doing our best to weed out
the people who are trying to troll us I
[Laughter]
can't even believe it that's a real
scholarship I can't believe that that's
really yeah I don't I I totally believe
it I believe in hundred percent that
totally sounds like something a Randi
and would do Hank let's answer a couple
more questions before we get to the
all-important stunning news from AFC
Wimbledon and then whatever news from
Mars all right we have a question this
one's from Orlando who asks dear Hank
and John I'm soon going to be moving
into a new place with my partner and I
wanted to know if you guys had any
suggestions for cool pets that would be
suitable for a small apartment assuming
the apartment allows pets we like the
idea of having tardigrades although we
don't know how well that would work I
like the idea of having a spider but my
partner partner is against that yes any
suggestions are welcome
tardigrades are a fantastic idea and you
really can't go wrong the things can
live in the vacuum of space so I don't
think you're gonna kill them yeah I mean
tardigrades are one of the very few pets
that you're unlikely to kill my main
recommendation would be
if you want to step up from tardigrade
in terms of responsibility I would
recommend a fish I'm a big fan of just
the single or maybe even like three or
four fish in a tank mm-hmm yeah it's
good to have more than one so they're
not so they're not lonely we have a fish
tank at the office and and we they were
all patreon perks so people give us
money on patreon and we would give them
the fish and named it after them or name
it whatever they wanted us to name it
and there's a fish in the tank named
Callie awesomesauce and Callie
awesomesauce started to eat all the
other fish not like whole hold just you
know pecking at the tail until the fish
couldn't swim anymore and died and then
it would eat the fish after it fell to
the bottom or rose to the top so Callie
awesomesauce now has her own tank and
and is all alone in Caitlin Hofmeister
his office sorry about that Callie
awesomesauce though that fish is very
healthy and doing very well and it might
be because it has eaten the the flesh of
younger fish yes it is one of the only
original fish that is still around from
our first round of of patreon
fundraising three years ago no a year
ago I am reminded as I so often am
during this podcast of the million
dialogue between the Athenians and the
millions in which the Athenians said the
strong do what they will and the weak
suffer what they must cali awesomesauce
clearly the strong yes doing what she
will when Kathryn and I first moved and
moved in together we got gerbils and and
the only problem we had with the gerbils
was at first we accidentally got a male
and a female and that turned out whether
or not they were first cousins to end in
babies they were not postmenopausal and
we thought that we had two girls we did
not so we had to take them back and to
have the pet store you know they got
free gerbils out of the deal and we got
another pair of gerbils that were indeed
different genders I mean you don't want
them to be different you want them to be
the same that is what I meant yes right
okay good I just wanted to get her yeah
I mean my we had a we had a pet hamster
growing up who
our terrible dog red/green eventually
ate but if I was gonna rank my pets
according to how much I love them and
how effective they would be as pets
living in a very small apartment I I
think the top five would all be fish and
then the sixth would be the hamster that
red/green ate and then the seventh would
be a tiny turtle and then the eighth
would be a dog yeah yeah I think that
the main things that I would try to
avoid are anything that lives longer
than 10 years so birds are just a
tremendous amount of responsibility
especially smart birds like parrots or
conyers because they require a lot of
stimulation or they go nuts right and
and you don't necessarily want to sign
up for that you know Jarrell's and
hamsters live like three years so
they're not too much of too much it's
sad you know it's that when they go but
you don't want to go in for too much and
fish are the same way where they don't
they can live very long but don't tend
to and reptiles live for a long time and
insects are just no not they're not a
pet no just a that's just weird the
other enemies just weird
um ah they are not our friends I love
bugs don't get me wrong I I do think
that they are our friends I love hanging
out with and seeing cool bugs but I
think that they unless you are like
really sort of into the idea of being an
insect breeder and like doing that it's
a complicated thing to do but having a
sort of menagerie of insects if that's
the kind of you know if you're that kind
of dork yeah I'm all for it go for it
nerd I love you but I don't know man
it's just it's a lot of work especially
carnivorous bugs because then you have
to be having other bugs to feed to the
bug and they smells bad yeah so in
summary we've decided that you should
get a fish Orlando you should probably
get a fish congratulations in advance on
your new fish or multiple fish well Hank
you know what the plural of fish is
that's true that's true God dang it it's
time for the news from Mars a Nancy
Hey yes what is the news from Mars the
news from Mars comes to us from just
outside of Mars the orbit of Mars in
fact where Phobos Mars's moon one of
Mars's two moons is being ripped apart
by Mars's gravity Oh Phobos is too close
to Mars it is not in a stable orbit it
will eventually crash into the surface
of Mars in tens of millions of years
before that happens we have now
determined Phobos will be ripped to
shreds and will fall as a bunch of small
rocks
Phobos it turns out is is a bunch it's
basically a bunch of rubble that has
stuck together and has been covered in a
layer of like dust and stuff just a
layer of like yeah basically just just
small or very small rocks and and so it
looks solid but it has this like ten ten
to a hundred meter thick layer of dust
on top of it which is quite a lot of
dust but it is it is not this solid as
it looks and it has these weird stripes
on it that that we initially assumed
were because of some very large impact
that created a rippling destruction
throughout the entire moon because these
stripes go from the the top to the
bottom of the moon but it turns out that
those stripes are in fact the weak
points in the moon as it is getting
stretched out by Mars's gravity as it
approaches the planet and those and that
is that is the beginning of Phobos being
torn to pieces by Mars's gravity which
is kind of terrifying yeah that's
horrifying I'm once again as I so often
find myself feeling glad that I don't
live on Mars yeah wouldn't ya wouldn't
it be kind of a you be interesting to
like look at the moon and be like in ten
million years that thing's gonna kill us
well I mean is it definitely gonna kill
everyone on Mars huh well no I mean you
have ten million years to deal with it
was just gonna inconvenience Oh probably
if this were happening to our moon and
but if it were happening to our moon if
our moon you know we've talked about
this before that if our moon oddly
enough that if our moon broke up
it would destroy all life on Earth if
our moon hit the earth it would destroy
everything
yay Phobos is not as big but neither is
Mars so I don't actually know what would
happen but I imagine that it would be a
very significant catastrophe on the
surface of Mars for anyone or anything
that was living there
however with 10 million years to spare
chances are you could throw something up
there just a few million ion thrusters
or maybe some nuclear warheads and blast
it into a stable orbit hmm I think that
I think we could do that I think that
that's all terrifying and we should talk
about Ligue 2 football the real stuff
[Laughter]
all right
Oh Hank it's been a it's been it's been
a wonderful week for AFC Wimbledon they
won their second consecutive game again
scoring more than two goals they beat
York City 3-1 yeah you'll remember from
from our last podcast Hank the our new
striker Lyle Taylor Mudd the montserrat
Ian international from the the island of
Montserrat yes well he he as you know he
you know it like every every nation has
its own team and then you know all the
players play for different clubs like
Leo Messi he's Argentinean but he plays
for Barcelona well Lyle Taylor's is
Montserrat Ian but he plays for AFC
Wimbledon he scored in his only goal for
his in his only game for the monster at
national or in his first game for the
Montserrat national team he scored
against Chris ow I was very exciting and
he scored in the game against York City
as did Tom Elliot and odd a Aziz so that
Tom Ali it's very interesting
interesting interesting kid he's all 24
now and he's he was looking very
promising I think he had a long spell at
Cambridge United he spent about three
years there and he's just come over to
AFC Wimbledon and he's looking he's
looking right likable and and audio zis
is is is looking really good too so
we're looking like we have a good strong
attacking game like we can finally score
some goals and our back floor played
much better than at any point in the
season and so suddenly we are in the
top half of the table which is
definitely where we want to be were 12th
right now where we're 12th on 22 points
and we're only amazingly we're only
three points we're only one victory away
Hank from being right there in the
playoff picture right there in that top
seven where we want to be at the end of
the season so right it's definitely good
to put together two wins in a row for
the first time this season definitely
exciting stuff all right
let's yeah keep this straight the string
go and get a turkey it's not what it's
called yes we're gonna try for the
turkey this weekend or last weekend man
it's it's hard to keep on top of the
podcast it does rather take the heat out
of the out of the out of it takes a
little bit of the excitement out knowing
that it happened in the past but
happening in my future Saturday morning
at 10:00 a.m. Eastern Time AFC Wimbledon
versus Hartlepool Hartlepool Hank being
one of the very few English football
league teams I have seen play in real
life I saw them plays Swindon a few
years ago why don't you just move to the
UK you could watch all the games yeah I
mean that's true and I've certainly I've
certainly asked my wife on on many
occasions if it would be alright for me
to just buy a league to football team
and and live out my dream of of owning a
you know a minor league professional
soccer team in England and she feels
that that there are things that we can
do that could have a greater impact on
our community and that would be better
for our family I think that she's full
of it but but she makes a compelling
argument all right John well thank you
for the news from AFC Wimbledon I'm
proud of your boys they are right
likable which is a thing that you said
that I assume you have got from the men
in Blazers I don't think so I think that
comes although I think that that's just
for me okay I think I invented that
myself what did we learn today Hank we
learned that that corndog doughnuts are
not corndog doughnuts unless the dog is
buried inside not on
we learned that your spouse is always
your relative but sometimes is really
your relative the people in the audience
learned that red green the dog that once
pooped in mind a Nintendo also ate my
hamster which is not a not a thing I
think we've told the audience before and
of course we learned that there's no
wrong way for someone else to install
their toilet paper absolutely accurate
do not mess with other people's toilet
paper thanks so much for listening to
dear Hank and John you can email us your
questions at Hank and John at gmail.com
or you can use the hashtag dear Hank and
John on the Twitter's I'm John Green on
Twitter Hank is Hank green and if you
want to follow Hank green on his social
media of choice that snapchat he's Hank
GRE that's correct this podcast is
edited by Nicholas Jenkins the music is
from gunnarolla at youtube.com slash
gunnarolla two r's 2 l's and as they say
in our hometown don't forget to be
[Music]
you